je viens dans notre patrie tesco j'ai
manqué il va me manquer
[Applaudissements]
c'est son dernier jour si on évite wade
a fait un travail exceptionnel sur la
chaîne son dernier journal d'abou il va
nous manquer et sachez le xavier on sait
pas encore ce que vous allez faire je
sais que vous avez les propositions de
14,2 de kellogg's c'est pourtant ce que
vous allez faire mais en tout cas vous
allez le faire vous avez vous avez quand
même retrouvé un boulot avant le costume
parce que ça peut m'aider peut-être
qu'on sait jamais en tout cas je
voudrais dire
xavier est un patron formidable et c'est
vrai que voilà il a été très présent à
chaque fois et c'est vrai qu'il a vu des
choses ici formidable je sais que vous
ne serez plus jamais déguisé en bourdon
voilà